well speaking of women empowerment all
of that involved in your story
move over Angelina Jolie Michelle Obama
is now the most admired woman in the
world so according to a new poll by
market research firm YouGov the former
first lady sits at the very top of the
worldwide popularity charts overtaking
Angelina Jolie and I think when you just
consider her story I know Gail just
spoke to her last weekend at the essence
festival or the weekend before but she
has a story that I think resonates with
a lot of people around the world
hard-working humble beginnings so you
know she connects with people and she is
now one of the most popular women in the
world I want to quiz you guys who do you
think is number two I think I saw it up
there number two give me a memo that is
a measure of Harry Potter right there
power of Harry plow very powerful in my
house I'll tell you Hillary Clinton came
in at number eight in Melania Trump at
19 so you know just recognizing great
people doing great things